du rock'n'roll à maurepas de la country
à croissy-sur-seine des ambiances
différentes pour célébrer le début de
l'été mais aussi la musique avec un
grand m
pour cette 38e édition de la fête de la
musique la ville de croissy sur seine a
permis au public de traverser
l'atlantique et de vivre à l'heure
américaine
[Musique]
ça fait partie du raid américain
relié à la musique américaine avec les
équipes de l'équipe féminine de foot
américain et croatie les accueils à
maurepas
la musique s'est invitée sur les
terrasses de plusieurs commerçants
au programme de la bonne humeur de la
convivialité et du rhum
[Applaudissements]
on est sur quelque chose aussi qui
rassemble les générations qui permet
aussi de sortir du travail d'avoir un
bon moment ensemble
c'est de retrouver des groupes musicaux
différents
dans les quartiers et de s'y rendre
compte on veut jusqu'à tard le soir
[Musique]
c'est à un bon événement pour faire la
fête justement des on y découvre des
artistes
généralement il fait beau va cesser le
mois de juin donc annoncé super sympa
comme événement c'est un endroit
convivial où l'on recourt comme pas mal
de gens ont peut on peut s'amuser boire
un p'tit coup voilà attention avec
l'alcool
évidemment si on conduit mais par contre
j'espère que cette année encore plus de
120 pays à travers le monde ont fêté en
musique le plus beau jour de ma vie